[Music]
no off-season programs mean no
opportunity for players who want new
contracts to take a stand with dak
prescott franchise tagged by the cowboys
one of the big pressure points was
whether or not he would show up for the
offseason program unsigned no obligation
to be there christian mccaffrey entering
the fourth year of his rookie contract
growing buzz he wants his second deal
sooner rather than later and i think a
fight is looming between mccaffrey and
the carolina panthers with no offseason
program there's nothing for mccaffrey to
stay away from chris this takes off the
table some juicy stuff we'd have been
talking about this month and some
interesting things that may have been
happening in the nfl
i don't know how it ultimately plays out
at some point they're going to get
players together and players who want to
take a stand can take a stand then but
for dak prescott specifically the
deadline is july 15. that's the real
deadline that's when the window closes
on doing a multi-year contract for
anyone with the franchise tag so whether
or not he stays away from the off-season
program there's going to be one most
likely for him and the cowboys july 15
is when they get a long-term deal done
or they don't for mccaffrey it's a
little bit different because he's under
contract that fight is going to continue
to simmer and we'll see it possibly come
to a head when it's time to show up for
training camp
well yeah all right so first the dak
prescott won when you look at this right
at you know take it as face value you go
oh the players are going to lose
leverage here
but i'm not so sure about that when you
talk about dak prescott in that part of
the conversation you know let's put it
this way all right no long long term
deals done i mean nothing gets done dax
unhappy it's a shortened training camp
oh we're not going to start till you
know late august whatever it may be
you know i i i just think you know all
right so you're right there's no
leverage they're lost their leverage i
don't know what else to say there i was
going to go down a wormhole and i'm
wrong as i'm sitting here thinking about
it here's where i thought you were going
to go though here's what i thought you
were going to go let's let's work
through this together yeah go ahead
to the extent that they do have some
sort of a virtual off-season program
that entails dak prescott meeting with
mike mccarthy through his computer
through his ipad through his surface we
want to make sure we mention all brands
um right you you you know if if dax says
sorry mike i'm not gonna be there that's
where i wanted
is not showing up so then will the
cowboys leak to somebody dak is is
giving mike mccarthy the virtual middle
finger by not being involved my guess is
the cowboys probably will go there and
will leak that so it changes the fight a
little bit because this isn't an issue
of failing to show up at the facility
this is an issue of failing to show up
at the computer and not cooperating and
you know what in a roundabout way
yes
it makes it harder because
right okay
why don't you think
well because
let me let's play let's play it out the
these are these are very strange times
with a high degree of stress on everyone
and this this notion that we're all
going to come together and find
solutions and teams are coming together
and finding solutions finding
simulations finding replacements for the
work that they would be doing at the
facility
and instead of doing what he has to do
to help his team get ready for the
season dak prescott the leader of the
team is refusing to participate is
refusing to set aside his personal
contractual demands and participate in
these efforts to salvage something out
of an off-season that's been
sent off the rails by the pandemic i
just think that it's a tougher pr self
for him
to not participate in this on the fly
effort to do something to get everyone
on the same page versus him making that
strategic stand that very public showing
of i'm not going to be there for the
offseason program until i get my
contract now look yeah it doesn't mean
it's impossible but it's going to be a
tougher sell from a pr standpoint to
stay away from these these at-home
sessions
agreed and i'm glad i worked with you
because you got my brain straight there
is what i was trying to say you're
exactly you know you're exactly right
but still business is business and it's
not dak prescott even though times are
weird and it might seem a hair
insensitive or whatever for the times it
doesn't matter it's still the world of
football and the nfl business and dak
prescott still has to play that game
whether it's zoom or face time or
showing up in person at otas he's got to
do what's best for him and my point was
that let's say the season gets pushed
back right let's say all of a sudden
they go all right we're probably gonna
have a shortened season and really hey
all nfl teams we're gonna have a
shortened training camp we're gonna do
it all in like three or four weeks
everybody's gonna get two preseason
games and we're just gonna start the
season and get going if you're dak
prescott and you've done nothing as far
as the whole offseason and now you're
gonna have a really short training camp
you know to me that puts more pressure
on the dallas cowboys to go oh man our
quarterback he has no clue some of the
new stuff we're doing he's really behind
the eight ball here and now as a team
we're really behind the eight ball and
that puts more pressure on the jones
family to go man i don't know how
confident i feel about our team you know
starting the season hitting on all
cylinders that's where i wanted to go
i'm a little stupid sometimes i'm blonde
and i'm from new jersey it's a bad
combination and it's early in the
morning so hello
yeah i mean
this changes everything for the same
reason the teams go into a new mode of
planning and strategizing i think
players who are trying to get new
contracts have to go back to square one
and ask themselves what's our best play
here christian mccarthy does he give
matt roll the middle finger when it's
time to sit down at his computer and
participate in zoom video conferences
aimed at learning his new playbook that
that that and and and here's the thing i
don't think that's important with him
though as far as like dak prescott you
know because he doesn't have to know the
audibles the checks the running back is
just like hey run to the right run to
the left yes there's nuances i'm not
trying to simplify it that much but i
don't know if it would scare the coaches
and the organization as much as a
quarterback as what is my point there
i i just i'm trying to wonder here what
a team's reaction will be if a player
says
i'm not going to participate in the
at-home learning until you pay me some
teams may say are you kidding me we're
doing the best we can to make chicken
salad here you're either part of this
team or you're not
and i just feel like the business issues
are secondary so many of the issues that
we otherwise would care about in our
society so many of the things that we
otherwise would be worried about becomes
secondary to dealing with this pandemic
and i just feel like for a football team
that is trying to salvage in some way
shape or form communication preparation
and planning for the season it's just
going to be harder for guys to take a
stand it's going to be more delicate for
guys to take a stand and i'm going to
spend some time today trying to fish
around and see what dak prescott is
planning to do once they realize and
once they decide on what the replacement
for the offseason program will be
because look here's another example of
how the nfl may not be as up to speed as
it needs to be chris
the programs were supposed to open
yesterday there's no final agreement
with the union on what's going to take
their place right so already they're a
day behind where they would have been on
the calendar from the standpoint now for
phase one it's just a simple basic
training yes cardio but at some point
we're going to get to the point where
they're missing out on the opportunities
to learn from the coach and if it's not
going to happen at the facility it's got
to happen another way and they need to
get that all worked out and everyone
needs to be on the same page and the
bottom line is dak prescott needs to
adjust whatever strategy he had if he
wasn't going to show up
for the offseason program at the
facility he needs a new strategy for how
he's going to participate or not in
these at-home preparation sessions as he
continues to try to get his new contract
before that july 15 deadline when the
window closes on a multi-year deal for
franchise tagged player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports